[Musik]
ja da hat der vollidioten club wieder
wandertag und damit herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine lieben freunde zu dem
ersten video aus meinem neuen auftritt
in hamburg
im ernst meine lieben freunde wir haben
uns hier heute versammelt denn ich habe
seit monaten schon keine neuen teil mehr
meiner serie was machen die hersteller
von desinfektionsmitteln gerade was sie
reiben sich die hände
[Musik]
könnte mir vielleicht mit dem bohrer im
kopf cornwall hack'n'slay tel
19 uhr 36 am freitagabend da kann man
ruhig mal ein bisschen was in der wand
drücken
warum laufen nasen während füße riechen
mama ja das ist ein richtiger sprachen
lernen
das sind so typische mütter nachrichten
auf worte wie können einfach nur von
mamas kommen und genau das ist auch beim
nächsten watts entfällt der fall
ihr schreibt eine person nämlich fahre
in zehn minuten zu machst dann schreibt
er
13 minuten später das ist dann so
zeitmanagement mäßig wie das auch bei
mir vorhanden
13 minuten später schreibt er auf jeden
fall bin jetzt weg bis später und die
mutter fragt dann eine minute später
wohin mama wahrscheinlich was meine
mutter an typisch eltern auch so was wie
was machst du gerade
mama privatsphäre auch jetzt beim
nächsten woche haben wir wieder eine
typische mama nachricht am start und
zwar fragt sie bist du wach nee nee nee
was soll ich schreiben wenn ich einige
jahre und weiß nicht wann aber wenn ich
lese schreibe dann liegen aber ja dass
der lehrer meinte heute zu uns dass wir
einfach die hand heben sollen wenn wir
auf toilette müssen und naja und das
hilft
bruder
oder schwester
da
neudingen da da da dazwischen bei diesen
gender sagt was werde ich nie verstehen
damit menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend dann bekommst du die gab es
heuer granz hier schreibt auf jeden fall
eine oma an ihr enkelkind wann bekommst
du kinder und das enkelkind antwortet
hannover mir geht es auch gut danke der
nachfrage wie geht es dir so hast du
schon zu mittag gegessen
liebe grüße lily ich habe dich etwas
gefragt ist es bei euch auch so habt ihr
schon mal irgendwie so druck aufgebaut
bekommen von verwandten von wegen
wie läuft es bei dir in der liebe soll
es da nicht mal vorangehen wenn du
kriegst du nur endlich eine freundin
luca ich bin single
erst ein paar jahre so weißt du was
gegen den corona virus hilft was sich
die hände mit pfefferspray einzusprühen
wtf warum weil man sich dann nicht
dauernd ins gesicht fasst das
das
irgendwie dumm aber halt auch in wien
ich hab ja wie geht's dir ich habe einen
klasse witz für dich auch mama was sagt
ein heim wenn er einen surfer sieht
keine ahnung das ist aber nett serviert
so mit frühstücks brechen
man muss sich mal wieder
das ist das ist gut
das sah gearbeitet wird mala will
schluss machen alter will zu reden ich
will auch schluss machen hat dann macht
schluss ja machen wir auch was
was so also ich habe mir nur eine e mail
account bei gmx gemacht und wollte
fragen ob du apfelkuchen mach ich
siebzehn gern sicher finde sowas erdung
von danke für dein passwort mama
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
watts empfehle ich bin eine mutter und
ich habe keine ahnung von dem was ich
gerade mache
wisst ihr eltern beziehen wir
hauptsächlich mütter haben von ganz ganz
vielen dingen ganz ganz ganz ganz viel
ahnung beispielsweise wirklich sowas wie
wäschewaschen oder so haushalt liche
sachen so da frage ich immer meine mom
aber so ein paar dingen
er hat sie wirklich komplett versagt
und auf der nummer eins ist technik und
nummer zwei
sonst kann meine mama eigentlich alles
manchmal wenn du das hier siehst du bist
echt wahnsinn wieder stellt ihm
bevorsteht darin die kuh von 300 ha ha
ha was ich alles machen könnte ha ha pro
das wird nicht in prozent gemessen
hahahahaha genau deswegen bin ich auf
hauptschüler h
es ist doch die guten langsam leo hat
schluss gemacht
das bitte mit mama wow ja das wäre auch
so die reaktion von meinem vater wenn
ich einen song schreiben würde papa ich
wünsche mir ein pony zu weihnachten ok
als wenn ich liebe dich sowieso freust
du dich so bei einem friseurtermin punkt
es ist schon vom niveau her ganz tief
die nächste whatsapp nachricht wurde von
einer person um 254 abgeschickt und
vertreibt diese person hey vanessa den
vater ist ja taxifahrer ja harvey so
antwortet vanessa um 9 uhr 30 morgens
und um 11 antwortet die person dann
wieder habt ihr das betrunken
geschrieben gestern weil ich mich
gefragt habe ob man geld zurückbekommen
wenn das taxi rückwärts fährt ja das ist
die dümmste aussage die ich je gehört
habe so thorsten kennst du das wlan
passwort der hölle was laberst du
fragezeichen yapi ist das pw vom wlan
der hölle und das ist lustig weil pi ist
unendlich lang
so thorsten m
ich sehe dich nicht jetzt so als
comedian mama irgendwie komme ich mit
überflüssig vor also so generell im
leben nicht irgendwie jetzt nur in
unserer familie der schule oder dem
fußballverein ich kann gerade nicht
der eltern job morgen dann zwei
körnerbrötchen und ein croissant hat
dich lied gute nacht lied very well in
your bettgestell ich glaube ich will
doch nicht mit ihm frühstücken morgen
das ist ein richtiger marwitz wieder
sleep very well in your bettgestell
warum
ich glaube der bilderrahmen ist spd
hallöchen popöchen sagt so was nicht
mama guten tach omama damit mit vc oder
crocodile warum das heißt engage
ich sage mal mama das sind gar nicht
meine mutter aber meinem namen könnte
genau sowas schreiben auch eine ganz
kurze side story dazu meine mom hat
vorgestern mit meiner schwester
telefoniert und ich bin in der
ortsgruppe mit ein paar freunden und
auch mit meiner schwester und meine
schwester dann einfach eine mail
reingeschickt die meine mom an meine
schwester geschickt hat und zwar stand
dort das drin
[Musik]
ja das ist das ist unsere margen in der
nacht stellen das ist mir so ich muss
dir was sagen du wurdest adoptiert was
ich will sofort meine echten eltern
kennenlernen wir sind keine echten
eltern und jetzt mach dich fertig du
wirst in 20 minuten abgeholt wtf ist das
eine kranke wendung der ereignisse
kommen allerdings auch schon zum letzten
wort fällt fürs heutige video meiner
lieben freund und zwanziger ihr zwei
frösche sitzen am teich da fängt es an
zu regnen meint der eine lass uns in den
teich springen sonst werden wir noch
nass mama ich bin 18
fühlt ihr euch wenn ihr mit euren eltern
schreibt auch mal so als wärt ihr 5
beziehungsweise ihr fühlt euch so
behandelt als wärt ihr 5
com
nach aus